Ross Tucker joining us on the program
Ross Tucker podcast and let me see what
else do you have here countdown to the
draft that's you better you bet
countdown to the draft vailable on radio
comm app and Ross joins us on the
program hopefully I got that
introduction correct but you liked this
McCaffrey deal so the introduction was
great Dan thank you great to talk with
you I like it for Chrismukkah varèse as
for the Panthers listen Dan he had
unbelievable leverage here I mean
unbelievable leverage
first of all okay they just lost Luke
Kuechly to retirement they cut Cam
Newton and they moved on from Greg Olson
he's not just the face of the franchise
Dan he's the only face on the team that
des fans even recognize right now so
you've got your best player and he is
absolutely that the face of the
franchise with a new head coach and the
number one thing that Matt rule does not
want in August when hopefully we have
training camps and he's in front of his
football team for the first time the
last thing he wants is for his best
player and face the franchise to not be
sitting in that room and every day he's
being asked by the media about the
Christian McCaffrey holdout and here's
the thing he was going to hold out Dan I
mean look this is the first kid that
ever skipped the ballgame the Sun Bowl
you know three years ago his dad played
in the NFL they know what the deal is
they know he's eligible for a contract
now and they know his unprecedented
usage the last two years he wasn't
playing until he got this and the
Panthers knew it yeah but why don't I
wait for one more year because I don't
have to give it to him now it's a four
year and then that fifth year option
right yeah well by that argument if
you're talking straight business of
football right you could argue have them
play this year out you then had on the
fifth year option in 2021
then franchise him in 2022 and if we're
just talking about maximizing the
business from the salary cap portion of
it then I get that but the reality is he
wasn't going to show up there and and
they know that and they know that he
knows the business and they got the
coronavirus going on they're trying to
have people renew their season tickets
for a lot of different reasons
he sells over half the jerseys down
there they just and by the way we don't
know what the structure of it is it's
four more years at the end of this deal
by the way they didn't rip up his final
two years it goes through 2025 so they
still have him for the next two years on
that other deal they just gave him some
bonus money now and let's see what the
structure is but they know that he
wasn't going to show up and neither the
owner nor the head coach wanted to deal
with that so it's a it's a six-year deal
and it's he'll be 29 I think when when
this is done which as much as they see
when you're running back and you're good
then they give you more touches which
puts you in the harm play harm's way
because you're so good if you're a great
defensive back nobody throws it your way
but a running back I got a load you up
and give him 400 touches at some point
can I just move him in and you know he
becomes a slot receiver instead of a
runner like I'd at some point I have to
try to get my money out of this and
that's what I think Carolina is gonna
face here at some point yeah and you
know I did a lot of work on this dad
because I wrote about this three weeks
ago for the athletic I wrote an open
letter to Christian McCaffrey saying you
have to hold out maybe they both read it
I don't know but here's what's crazy
he played ninety three percent of the
snaps last year for Carolina there's
only three running backs that played
more than 75% of the snaps say Kwan's
eek
and Leonard fournette and then you look
at like Leonard fournette was second
with 88 percent of the snaps but he
played a hundred and thirty-eight fewer
place than McCaffrey that's like three
games
in fact only fournette and Zeke had more
than 805 snaps
whereas McCaffrey had over 1050 which
means he was on the field for over 250
more plays than everybody but deacon for
net dan that for most running backs
that's like six or seven games the guy
played essentially an extra half season
from every other guy at his position
they ran him into the ground laughter
it's not just how many touches he had it
just how many plays he's out there
because even if you're not getting a
carry right you still have to take on a
blocker I mean you're still out there
hitting somebody doing something and his
usage is off the charts I've never seen
anything like it which is another reason
why he was not gonna play this year
especially with them having to use them
again this way unless he got this money
it's not gonna rush sucker former NFL
lineman so if McCaffrey wasn't gonna
show up does that mean my homes or
Watson or DAC aren't showing up either
I think they should strongly consider it
especially deshaun Watson when you look
at the disaster of a GM he has down
there in Houston and what's going on
with the Texans you are eligible for a
new contract after your third year and
these teams can all decide whether or
not they want to try to string it out
and play hardball like the Cowboys are
but then the players themselves on the
other side can decide how they're going
to handle it it just came out that Dax
not going to show up because he's not a
signed player for the virtual offseason
so now you're going to have all these
meetings and starting quarterbacks not a
part of any of these meetings now it
almost benefits the Cowboys that it's
virtual because if they were really
having these meetings with the new head
coach and mike mccarthy who's going to
have some tweaks to Kellen Moore's
offense and your starting quarterbacks
there it's almost like what's the point
I mean what's the point of view having
the meetings if the guy who by far is
the most important person to be in the
meetings isn't there so both sides have
leverage that they can use I think both
mahomes and deshaun Watson
my suspicion Dan is that both Watson and
mahomes are waiting for the other one
yes to sign well they're waiting between
the hours first they're waiting for dak
and then it's then it'll be watching in
mahomes to see who gets to 41st I agree
I think that's what's going on there
whereas McCaffrey realizes he cannot go
out there what's really interesting to
Dan about the running back position
there's a bunch of other guys in
McCaffrey's draft class right so Aaron
Jones from the Packers Alan Chimera
Saints Dalvin a Vikings all very good
players similar to McCaffrey probably
not quite as McCaffrey but very similar
but they're not nearly in the same
situation because none of those guys
have the same usage none of those guys
are the faces of their franchise they
don't have a new head coach so it's
going to be real interesting cuz all
those guys their agents are going to
argue that they should get 16 million a
year as well and those teams are gonna
laugh I mean like the Saints Vikings and
Packers they're not given those guys
close to what McCaffrey just got from
the Panthers because the situations are
so unique I don't leave you with this I
just I started the top of this hour and
I said look this is this sounds crazy
maybe it is crazy but if I'm the Miami
Dolphins and I'm not completely sold on
to and I can't trade up to get Joe
borough why don't I just go into this
season with Brian Fitzpatrick use those
draft picks maybe trade back for
somebody who wants to move up and then I
sort of reassess where we are as a team
and are we in the sweepstakes for Trevor
Lawrence next year but if I have three
first-round draft picks right now if I
can get another one and have four in the
first round
I got wide receivers galore I got
offensive linemen galore I got a couple
of great defensive backs that maybe I
can get to so I can get four starters
out of this draft and I have Ryan
Fitzpatrick if I'm not sold on to a what
do you think of that philosophy well I
agree with you that I don't think that
they should take either to uh or Justin
Herbert
if they're not sold on them I don't know
that anybody would want to trade up to
five at that point because I think the
Charger's will just take either Herbert
or two after that I don't know if they'd
be able to trade down and get extra pics
maybe you know Kay but I think your
point remains which is don't force it
the irony of this whole thing then is
that everyone you talk to in Miami the
plan was basically to be the worst team
in the NFL this year so they could get
to uh but two things happened number one
- we got hurt and Joe Burrell was
unbelievable and number two for some
unknown reason they sign Ryan
Fitzpatrick who's like the anti tanker
you don't get it Patrick if you're
trying to lose okay so but what's crazy
about it is because of - of hurting his
hip and because if it's Patrick winning
five games or whatever they still might
be able to get the guy that everybody
thought they were going to get before
the year started at number one they
still might be able to get him at number
five I just it's a shame I wish it
wasn't this way Dan but in two years of
college football the guy broke his hand
had two ankle surgeries alabama invented
that I never heard of before had a hip
surgery like I would love to talk to
like an insurance actuary dude what are
the odds he's gonna stay healthy in the
NFL no you're not good I know those guys
who were injured in college you know
they get injured in the pros that
follows them in there it just does
there's a track record with them it's
great to talk to you as always we
appreciate your time and great stuff we
will talk to him absolutely see guys
that's Ross Tucker